Looking at the compound inequality we have, which we can also write in interval
notation, of course. Seems like, considering we have the same number, almost,
written twice, just one of it with a negative sign. There should be some sort of
simpler way to write this. It's not exactly redundant right now, but it seems a
little bit redundant. What we really know is that we want the difference between
0 so we want the distance it takes from on a number line to get from 0 out to
either end of the tolerance is just .3, either in the positive direction or the
negative direction. One way we can denote this is by using what's called
absolute value signs. We can think of the absolute value of a number as the
distance between that number and 0. This distance is absolute in that it ignores
direction. We can see that counting from positive point 3 back to zero takes us
point 1, point 2, point 3. But the same is true of negative point 3. Point 1,
point 2, point 3. So positive point 3 and negative point 3 have the same
absolute value, because they're the same distance from zero on the number line.
Now that you have an idea of what absolute value is, can you tell me what the
absolute value of negative 9 is? And what the absolute value of 4 and a half is?
The number line is here just for you to have a visual in case you feel like
counting on something.